uh one of the things that is a troubling
sign for joe biden is that even some
democrats now elected democrats are
backing away from saying absolutely i
would support joe biden's reelection in
2024 we're going to look at a clip of
tim ryan who uh i support in his race in
ohio for the senate it's a very
important race actually um he's running
against jp right
j.d mandel no he's running against jd
vance
and um
tim ryan's been on the show i think he's
i think he's great i hope that he wins
in ohio but
he is correctly reading the mood on the
ground in ohio
which is that even democrats don't
really want joe biden to run for
reelection now where do i get that will
i get it from polling
there is a majority of democrats at this
point that wants someone other than joe
biden to be the nominee in 2024.
tim ryan appeared on fox news and he was
asked would you support joe biden's
re-election in 2024 and he basically
punts and i think that there is a lot to
read into the punting but let's take a
look at the clip first
so we'll keep watching all that final
question to you there was the first
presidential primary state new hampshire
poll that came out yesterday and it
should support for this president
president joe biden for his re-election
it is plummeting in fact it suggested
that biden and buddha judge are now tied
in a hypothetical 2024 presidential
primary match-up do you support the
president in his re-election bid
i'm working now by the way the
question's a little bit silly because
joe biden hasn't actually filed for
re-election so so the question's a
little bit wonky uh they're not not
wrong the question's a little bit
squishy
uh but let's listen to the answer on my
own election and that's all i'm focused
on and sorry i talked over the key
moment so let's back it up and take it
from the top president in his
re-election bid
i'm working on my own election and
that's all i'm focused on right now
we've got a little under four months
here in ohio and we're running a great
campaign we're up in the polls and
working really hard so i'm just going to
focus on that and then we can chat about
that uh after i win and get in the
united states senate i'll be happy to
comment but i think it was it was noted
that that the president held a an event
there in your state recently a speech on
the economy i believe if my memory
serves me and you didn't show that was
certainly a message you were sending
right well it was an event where we
saved a hundred thousand pensions in
ohio through the rescue package which
was significant many of those teamsters
working class people it was a great
thing but i had commitments in southern
ohio and i'm not gonna back out on uh
normal ohioans average ohioans to like a
schedule that i had and then leave them
to go see the president like i'm not
doing that stuff these are great people
and i'm gonna i'm gonna keep my meetings
but we gotta get focused on the economy
all right so so i mean listen he's doing
some dancing and rightly so i had a
commitment and the economy is the focus
and all these things this is not a hard
thing to dance around
if you want to send a different message
right tim ryan could say you know it's
too early to talk about 2024
but i know that democrats will select a
great nominee and i will support that
nominee right okay so you he could have
said something like that
he didn't say that and there are two
interpretations one
tim ryan doesn't really like joe biden
for president i actually don't think
that's the case i think tim ryan likes
joe biden absolutely fine
tim ryan
is trying to win
a senate seat
in a sometimes red state of ohio
which would be hugely impactful for
democrats in the senate when there is a
huge fight for who's going to control
the senate next time tim ryan accurately
believes that ohio democrats and
independents and maybe some republicans
who could vote for him in november might
be soured on biden why do i say tim ryan
accurately believes that because that's
what the polling shows and i know people
get mad at me but joe biden has a low
approval rating it's historically low
it's the lowest at this point in his
presidency
compared to any president going all the
way back to truman in the second year of
his presidency in the middle of the
1940s so it is correct as an assessment
that biden's not popular and my guess
would be that tim ryan being
an ohio congressman and wanting to be an
ohio senator is aware that in ohio in
particular the numbers might be even
worse for biden than they are nationally
but the point here is
this can become a self-fulfilling
feedback loop
um the public becomes disillusioned with
biden which is happening it's it's what
the approval rating shows
uh and then this causes
democratic elected officials to back
away from biden
which furthers the
implausibility of a successful
re-election campaign which further
reduces the number of people that want
biden to run again it it can become this
feedback loop and it sort of seems to be
happening if the best strategy remember
into let me think now in 2008
when it was mccain versus obama obama
george w bush was basically missing from
the campaign trail
george w bush was a drag down based on
his approval for republicans wanting to
get elected john mccain included
is it possible that biden is going to
end up being the same
and the question will be answered in the
next few months does joe biden start
showing up at rallies in support of 2022
democratic candidates let me know what
you think find me on twitter
at dpakman make sure you're following me
there